je m'appelle victor dresny j'ai 28 ans
et je suis affecté à commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et
développement durable depuis maintenant
quatre ans et demi
il ya beaucoup de relations humaines au
sein du service avec l'administration
puis avec les services de l'état donc
que voilà avec l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires qui sont intéressés par
la politique publique bien sûr la
relation politique elle est fondamentale
dans notre métier on travaille plusieurs
fois par semaine avec plusieurs
sénateurs différents cas évidemment cet
aspect technique vous lisez beaucoup de
rapports beaucoup de notes beaucoup
d'études d'impact de textes de lois de
code etc ensuite il faut analyser
synthétiser et puis répondre à une
commande
le rapporteur pose une intention qui est
je souhaite qu'au niveau législatif on
puisse aller vers eux soit une
incitation soit une interdiction de
pratiquer tel et tel comportement moi à
partir de l'arbre je regarde quelle est
la ou comment en commun est rédigé
l'article déjà six et d'un point de vue
formel légistique tout est conforme à ce
que est ce qu'on peut attendre et
deuxièmement je vais essayer de
récupérer les idées qui émergent les
auditions trouver trouver ensuite
d'autres compléments apportés pour
répondre spécifiquement la commande de
mon sénateurs et à partir de là moi je
vais lui proposer un amendement donc je
vais lui rédiger un dispositif juridique
qui va permettre de traduire sa volonté
et ensuite il présentera cet amendement
soit alors en commission si on est au
stade de la commission soit en séance
publique si on essaie de la séance
publique il proposera ses collègues de
le voter
[Musique]
lors de l'examen du projet de loi climat
et résilience il y avait un sénateur qui
souhaitaient travailler en particulier
sur la déforestation a porté sur la
lutte contre la déforestation à porter
et donc le travail ça a été de lui
proposer un dispositif en fait qui va
permettre à d'obliger certaines
entreprises à réaliser un plan de
vigilance qui ensuite leur sera
opposable et qui pourra engager leur
responsabilité
la lutte contre la déforestation
apporter c'est un enjeu que chacun peut
percevoir comme extrêmement important et
là il ya une mesure qui a été prévu par
le sénat
[Musique]
ce qui est assez passionnant c'est cette
diversité de sujets et en même temps
voilà le caractère assez approfondies
vous pouvez voir des chercheurs on voit
des scientifiques faut avoir un esprit
assez curieux la proximité avec les
politiques la trouve très intéressante
puisque finalement vous participé à
l'exécution du service public
parlementaire qui constitue en fait à
appuyer les représentants de la
démocratie républicaine française telle
qu'elle s'est constituée